how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and today we
seemingly have some pretty big news
about a marvel villain that is going to
be making his way to the mcu very soon
and this villain isn't just going to be
appearing in one film it sounds like
this
villain is going to be the person
responsible for pulling many different
strings inside of the mcu
and could even be behind some other
villains that we'll see as early on as
phase four
and the villain that we're talking about
is modoc
modoc has been rumored to be entering
the mcu before specifically in ant-man 3
but now we have further evidence that
marvel studios does in fact
have some plans to use modok and it
seems like marvel studios has probably
been setting up modoc to appear in the
mcu since the very beginning of the mcu
with iron man 3 and then we could see
him pop
up in the current mcu as early on as
black widow
and i'll break down everything you need
to know in this video but first if
you're new be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
mcu news and so you can enter this
week's giveaway for a chance to win a
mysterio
funko pop all you gotta do is subscribe
like the video and comment down below to
enter
so recently we got the agents of shield
grand finale
agents of shield was an awesome tv
series and it's sad that it came to an
end but it was a good ride
and now of course that it's over
directors writers producers they're all
doing interviews
about the show and recently the av club
interviewed agents of shield executive
producers jed
whedon and jeffrey bell where they were
asked whether they were
ever stopped from doing anything in the
series and
jed whedon had quite a particular reveal
to talk about in a case where marvel
seemingly wanted to keep a character for
themselves to be able to use
elsewhere and here's what jed whedon
said about one particular character that
marvel studios seemingly kept for
themselves
he said we had a lot of ideas where we
were
and i'll say this i don't care we were
given the green light originally to use
certain characters from marvel and
started to break story based on those
character
coughs modok and then they retracted it
so there were a bunch of things that
were going to get a little crazy that
were above our pay grade
in terms of the toys we were allowed to
play with so modok was originally
supposed to be in
agents of shield marvel gave agents of
shield permission to use
modok but then they took it back they
said you can use them and then they said
no you can't and there's really only one
reason they would say that they can't
use this
character and that is because they have
plans for it
and since they have plans for it they
didn't want agents of shield to use it
because as we recently discovered
marvel's agents of shield did not really
exist in the mcu
different timelines different universes
so to speak so it seems like marvel
studios has plans to use modok in the
mcu and they didn't want modoc used in
marvel's agents of shield because they
didn't want any confusion about the
universes
so if marvel studios wasn't going to use
modok and the mcu there would be no
problem with agents of shield
using it in their series and it sounds
like in the beginning marvel studios
didn't have plans for modok in the mcu
but all of a sudden
they did now this is pretty coincidental
considering the fact that there have
been a lot of
modok and ant-man 3 rumors going around
and not to mention we have recently
discovered that paul
rudd ant-man himself has written a
script
for ant-man 3 that had modock in it now
as it stands right now
jeff loveness is writing ant-man 3. but
according to
the geeks worldwide he wasn't the first
writer
sources say that paul rudd wrote a draft
of the script that featured modoc and
his organization aim as the primary
antagonist
now if you're not aware paul rudd has
screenplayed credits on the first film
and a writing credit on the second film
so paul rudd is involved with the
writing and the screenplay
now we don't know what exactly paul rudd
wrote in his script although we do know
one thing
there was a mysterious benefactor in
ant-man and the wasp that sony burch was
working for
now they never did reveal who this was
but we know marvel they never mention
anything by mistake
they mention thanks and plant easter
eggs in movies way in advance
and they use these to set up future plot
points so it's widely believed that this
mysterious benefactor
is going to show himself in ant-man 3.
and recently the geeks worldwide
reported that there has been a
casting call for ant-man 3 4 the
mysterious benefactor
originally they heard that it could be
norman osborne but now they have heard
that it's going to be
modok and if this is true then modok is
that mysterious benefactor that sony
britch was working for in ant-man and
the wasp and that also means that
aim is going to be a primary antagonist
of the movie as well
so it does seem like some of paul rudd's
script is going to be happening in
ant-man 3 and there are a lot of
connections already in the mcu to aim we
were actually introduced to aim in
iron man 3. in fact they were pretty
much the main antagonists of the film
but they are not gone in fact it's
already been confirmed that they're
going to be in the first
movie of phase four black widow in the
trailer for black widow in one
particular scene where yelena belova
is on an operating table we can see next
to her that it says
aim meaning that the organization is
still around
and not only are they still around but
it seems like they're actually pretty
involved with the events of black widow
and
probably other future events in the mcu
as well if modok is popping up in
ant-man 3.
but there are actually even more
connections than just black widow for
starters we know that
thunderbolt ross is going to be in black
widow it's long been confirmed and now
he's in the trailers of course
and it's pretty much all but confirmed
that he's doing some pretty shady stuff
right now he already rebooted the weapon
x
program an incredible hulk and now in
black widow he's working with some super
soldier serum again
and of course let's not forget that he
is probably organizing the thunderbolts
as we speak but the question is are the
thunderbolts
his project or is somebody else pulling
the strings because you see in the
comics
modoc is actually responsible for the
creation of red hulk
and of course it is thunderbolt ross who
ends up becoming red hulk
so there are a lot of connections here
with aim
all the way back in iron man 3 in black
widow not to mention thunderbolt ross
and black widow
and now it seems like it's pretty much
all but confirmed that modok is the
mysterious benefactor from ant-man
and the wasp so it looks like aim and
modok are turning out to be bigger
villains than we thought they were going
to be just showing up in ant-man 3.
as it turns out modoc could be pulling
the strings in several different areas
of the mcu
that we'll find out soon in phase 4
phase 5 and beyond
so as far as ant-man 3 is concerned it
does seem like we have discovered the
villain
and modok is actually kind of a fitting
villain for ant-man 3.
modoc is pretty intense it's actually an
acronym that stands for mental organism
designed only for
killing but the ant-man films are comedy
films of course they're superhero films
but they're really funny films
and if we're being honest modoc looks
kind of funny and they could definitely
poke fun at that in ant-man 3.
does mother know you whereas her drapes
in the comics modoc undergoes
substantial mutagenic
medical experimentation originally
designed to increase his intelligence
and although the experiment was a
success he became very intelligent it
resulted in him having a freakishly over
developed head
his head is so big compared to his body
that he actually needs a flying chair to
move around
so although he is intense this would be
the perfect opportunity for ant-man and
louise to make fun of him so it seems
like we have our villain and it seems
like a really
really good fit but let me know what you
think about this how would you feel if
modok was the villain of ant-man 3
let me know all of your thoughts down
below in the comment section and don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you can stay up to date on all the
latest mcu news
for live updates you can follow me on
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof
you